[MUSIC PLAYING]
ABBY CAREY: Hi.
My name is Abby Carey, and
I'm a developer advocate
for Google Cloud DevTools.
And I'll be talking about
maximizing developer
productivity with Cloud Code.
So what are some development
challenges developers can face?
One would be repetitive
context switching.
You might find yourself
bouncing between a quick start
guide, three documentation
sets, your code
editor, and your terminal,
and your debugger
just to get your project up
and going and testing it out.
Then there's getting
started with GCP,
which can be intimidating.
You don't know where
to start, and you
can get overwhelmed by the
docs we throw out at you,
which is quite a bit of docs.
There's a lot of content.
The products we support
can also be complex,
a big one being Kubernetes.
And quite a few of our products
require YAML configuration
files.
You probably don't
like dealing with YAML.
You want to focus on your
code, not configurations.
So these issues I
mentioned usually
happen in the inner loop,
seen on the left here.
You're probably familiar
with this process.
This is your
day-to-day as a dev.
You code up a feature, build
it, test it, find a bug,
and then rinse and repeat
over and over again
until your feature's
looking good
and you're ready to
get into the outer loop
and then ship it
out to the world.
But how can we make these
development challenges
a bit better and improve
your productivity?
Well, that's where
Cloud Code comes in.
Cloud Code is an IDE plugin that
automates development workflows
for cloud-native applications.
This plugin is
composed of a bunch
of tools that can assist you in
a variety of workflows for GCP.
It integrates these tools
right into the UI of your IDE.
And these tools
automate repetitive
processes seen in
your inner loop.
Overall, it's here
to save you time
and make you more productive.
And looking back at
this picture again,
Cloud Code is all about focusing
on the left-hand side here.
So who can use Cloud Code?
If you're developing Java,
Python, Go, or Node.js,
chances are, we got you covered.
We support PyCharm,
IntelliJ, GoLand,
and WebStorm from JetBrains,
as well as the popular Visual
Studio Code, and more
recently, Cloud Shell Editor,
which allows you to use
Cloud Code in your browser.
So what are Cloud Code's
features at a glance?
First of all, it lets you
build, push, and deploy services
to Kubernetes and Cloud Run.
It has a simple UI, so it's
easy to rinse and repeat.
It also allows you to debug
Kubernetes and Cloud Run
services with the same UI of
your IDE that you're used to.
All you got to do is place a
break point and then hit Go,
and you're debugging your
Kubernetes or Cloud Run
services.
It also handles complex tasks,
like port forwarding, for you.
Then there's our
watch mode feature.
This triggers
rebuilds and redeploys
when code changes happen.
All you got to do is code
up your change, hit Save,
and then it triggers that
rebuild and redeploy,
speeding up your
development time overall.
Then there's Cloud Code's
most popular feature, which
is YAML authoring assistance.
You get YAML snippets,
linting, syntax highlighting,
and on-hover docs for
over 400 resource types.
And finally, there's
easy API discoverability,
with the ability to quickly
enable and get documentation
that you need right
from your IDE.
So what products does
Cloud Code support?
We support every
product, in a way,
because Cloud Code has
an API Explorer where
you can enable and get the
docs for all of GCP's APIs.
We also have YAML authoring
support for the big ones,
like Cloud Build and Kubernetes.
And we have UI integration
for three GCP products,
including GKE, Cloud
Run, and Secret Manager,
which means we give them
their own dedicated panels
within your IDE.
So focusing on Cloud
Code's Cloud Run features,
Cloud Code helps
you ramp up fast
on Cloud Run with
integrated samples
that show best practices.
You can also locally develop
an emulated Cloud Run
environment with just a
click and view the logs.
This is great for
catching issues
in a production-like
environment before it actually
has to go to production.
And once that's ready
and looking good,
you can deploy to Cloud Run
with just a couple clicks.
And finally, you can
view your services
and their properties
all from your IDE.
But let's look at
this in a demo.
All right, so this
is Visual Studio Code
with Cloud Code
already installed
from the IDE Marketplace.
And you can tell,
because to the left,
we have a stack of four
icons corresponding
to the big workflows for Cloud
Run and Kubernetes, et cetera.
Down below, we have the
Cloud Code status bar.
And when I click it, I can
create a new application.
I can pick between Kubernetes,
Cloud Run, or a custom
application.
But today, I'll use a
Cloud Run application.
And we get a
variety of languages
to pick from for
our starter app,
but I'll pick a Flask
Python example and clone it.
So this is our
example, ready to go.
There's a Docker file
included, so it's
ready to be containerised.
I also have a requirements.txt
file for any packages I need.
Yeah, so let's run this
in the Cloud Run Emulator.
I want to test this out locally
before deploying to the cloud.
The Cloud Run Emulator--
as I said earlier,
it's a production environment
to test out my service.
I'll go ahead and click
Cloud Code status bar button,
and then Run on
Cloud Run Emulator.
And then from here, I
can configure my service,
including container properties.
I will set Dedicated CPUs to 1
virtual CPU to better emulate
running on Cloud Run.
And then I can also switch
the Environment Variable tab
and specify
environment variables
for my service, and
Cloud SQL Connections,
if I'm connecting to
a Cloud SQL database.
Down below, I can
pick Build Settings.
I will be building with
Docker, but I could also build
with Buildpacks if I wanted to.
And then there's also
Advanced build Settings
if I pop open this
section here, where you
can specify build arguments.
And then there's a
checkbox down here
for automatically rebuilding
and rerunning on changes.
So this is that watch
mode I mentioned.
And I'll leave it on,
because I want to show you
the iterative development.
So right now, we are building
and then we will be deploying.
But let's check out
the detailed view here.
I can see everything going
on behind the scenes.
And then I will switch
back to the normal view.
And we can see that the service
has been deployed to localhost.
But instead of
clicking that URL,
I can also click the Cloud
Code status bar button.
And from here, I can
Turn Off Watch Mode,
Open my Deployment Logs,
or Open the Service URL.
I'll Open the Service URL.
And here is my service running
in the Cloud Run Emulator.
But what if I want to test
out iterative development?
I want to change this--
It's running!-- string
to something else.
So I'll minimize
this for the moment
and then I'll open app.py.
And I will find that string
and then update it to something
like, This is my service.
Yeah, that looks good.
And I'll hit Save, and that
will trigger a rebuild, as you
can see happening below, and
then, finally, a redeploy.
And we've got that service URL.
So I'll go ahead and
refresh my service.
And this is my service.
That string just updated.
That was a look at iterative
development with Cloud Code.
So I'll go ahead and close
that out and stop this.
But now I want to
test out debugging.
All I got to do, I'll place a
little breakpoint right here
on line 16.
Go to the Debugger
pane, and hit Play.
And I sped this up
a little bit here,
but we've specified
where we want to debug.
And I will go ahead
and open this up.
And when I open up my service,
it's kicked off debugging.
And now I will just step
through the code a little bit
here so you can
see what happens.
You can see the
variables coming up here.
My message is,
This is my service.
I got my service name.
You can also see stuff
going on in the call stack.
And I'll play to finish that
up and disconnect the debugger.
So this is looking
great, and now I
want to deploy it to Cloud Run.
So I'll go ahead and open
up the Cloud Run Explorer.
And here, you can see I
already have my project set,
and I have four existing
Cloud Run services.
But what if I want
to deploy a new one?
So up above, there is a
little Cloud button here,
and this will allow me
to deploy to Cloud Run.
I could also deploy it from
the Cloud Code status bar,
but we'll go this way.
So I have the option
to create a new service
or deploy a revision
to an existing service,
but I will create a new one.
And then going down, I can
select my deployment platform.
I will be going to
Cloud Run fully managed,
but we also support
Cloud Run for Anthos.
Going down more, I will allow
unauthenticated invocations
of this Cloud Run service.
I can specify a service
account if I want.
And you'll see those
advanced settings
that you saw when I was
setting up the Cloud Run
Emulator for local testing,
including environment variables
and Cloud SQL connections.
And this time, for
build settings,
I'm going to switch from
Docker to Buildpacks,
just because I can.
So this is if you didn't
have a Docker file,
we could use a Buildpack.
And I've sped this
up a little bit,
but we are building
and deploying.
And in the Cloud
Run Explorer, you
will see hello-world-1 pop up.
Yep, so our service
has deployed,
and we're given a little
URL to the right here.
And I will open that up.
And this is our Cloud Run
Service running in the Cloud
on Cloud Run.
So back to the
Cloud Run Explorer,
I can open up this
hello-world-1 service here.
And I can see my
existing revisions.
I only have one right
now, so 100% of my traffic
is going there.
If I open that up, I can see
the properties of my revision,
including how much traffic is
coming to it, its container
port, and CPU allocation.
And if I close that--
and I can right click my
service and easily get
the URL of where
it's deployed to.
And I can deploy a new revision
with this little Cloud Code
button, or view my logs
with this button here.
So that was a look at Cloud
Code's Cloud Run support.
And I encourage you to download
Cloud Code and give it a try.
And join our Slack community if
you have any feature requests
or questions about Cloud Code.
[MUSIC PLAYING]